Americans didn't just vote for  candidates they also passed a number of  ballot measures across the country  Washington state approved one of the  toughest gun safety laws in the nation  the measure increases the age limit to  buy an assault rifle from 18 to 21 it  also imposes a 10-day waiting period for  purchases Michigan voters legalized  marijuana for recreational use and  medical marijuana was approved in Utah  and Missouri voters back Medicaid  expansion in Idaho Nebraska and Utah the  move covers an estimated 325 thousand  low-income residents their voters in San  Francisco approved attacks on businesses  that make more than 50 million dollars a  year now that money will go toward  housing for the homeless and  Massachusetts passed the first statewide  referendum to protect transgender rights  it upholds a bill prohibiting gender  identity based discrimination in public  places like bathrooms and locker rooms